we get to the papers Suzanne put us out
of our misery understand look I'm
reflecting on it very carefully I really
am taking soundings remembers and so on
and so forth I think the party's just
experienced the downsides of a new
leader who perhaps didn't quite reflect
carefully enough so i will make a
decision come to an informed decision
and i will make the announcement as and
when but not now but not today ok and
what about the shenanigans in strasbourg
what do you make that I think I think as
Nigel said it's very unseemly it's not
the way to men should behave in public
absolutely not you know you Kip is a
party that's got to get its act together
let's be honest we need to be the
Opposition in waiting as our very very
Swift former leader actually said
because the Labour Party is no
opposition so you just got to get its
act together and clearly event so you
think at the moment you're letting your
voters down I think the voters at the
moment would perhaps have every right
not to have the confidence in them that
I think they can have in the party I
think you Kip has got a huge role to
play going forward people are saying oh
you kids lost its focus lost its purpose
Breck's it's going to happen but I think
there's much more that we can be doing
and if that's aight i'm working on a big
policy document at the moment looking at
what you keep can offer to the electric
going forward and i'm very much looking
forward to launching that and that would
be the basis for a leadership domestic
my part of my day day job but but
absolutely i hope whoever is the new
leader will take some of those ideas for
all right well this is a paper review
let's dive into it Jenny you've got this
in the Sunday Times Louise Casey the
anti-extremism czar as she is Doug shall
report out angioma whole issue for what
she's finished it for several months and
it's not been released yeah that's the
point she's finished it and it's not out
now the interesting thing about this is
that Louise cases on the most impressive
civil servants that I've ever come
across she's very tough she's
independent minded she ran the troubled
families program she's the person he
went in and investigated the scandal of
what had gone on in roudram when all the
authorities had found to pursue the
cases of all those children who are
being abused and she was asked by David
Cameron and Theresa May to do a report
on what had gone wrong with the
extremism project and what was the
failure of integration in British
society
and she spent months working on it she's
apparently got very very trenchant
criticisms of the way the Home Office
has operated about the failure to have a
proper integration plan and clearly
ministers are so embarrassed by it that
they aren't putting it out and according
to the report today they're desperately
trying to rewrite it and turn it down
and Louise Casey has said through
friends that she's not going to let that
happen she's going to she's going to get
the facts out no matter what uh-huh I I
think this is you know i am quite
dubious about some of these government's
ours I think sometimes they're put in to
try and as a PR exercise when the
government's got a difficult problem
that it wants to solve and it wants to
make itself look good while we're doing
something we're putting in this
government's awww well I think Louise
Casey is quite rightly called their
bluff on this she's actually one of the
few that have done a good job she's done
something and now they're saying oh
because you've reached the wrong
conclusion wicked well this is where I'm
going the seventh young into something
continues come in on this sakurai mean
it seems like well it's some fail fail
fail in so many areas so 11 the sort of
things I mean the first one is um I did
history so I sort of tend to look back
in time it's remarkable how this country
consistently questions why it's being
very liberal with immigrants and
particularly political immigrants I was
going through the secret agent by Conrad
with my son about a week ago and it's
exactly safe a bunch of foreign
immigrants coming from the east with
with extremist ideas and then the
streets of love of it so it's an old
story and generally speaking this
country is remarkably good eventually at
integrating and so I'm all for
publishing a report because it's
important to integrate people but we
mustn't forget that this country is
really good at integrating people think
of the Jewish community that came from
Russia in the 19th century that was very
isolated in Whitechapel and for a long
time lift ultimus is a completely
isolated community and now it's a fully
a particularly but I think the point is
that we've seen that there have been
acute failures the highly communities
about integration and louise casey's
report is about let's not just turn our
eyes away from its orbit authorities the
day and when we can discuss it as we see
it but soccer bringing your story here
this is a front of the sunday experiment
that works a border that works at last
it hails yeah it's it's so just before I
took by the way I do not run out fun
I rather pension scheme which was always
working no no no matter who who who are
all working men all right and look about
the board works it I mean there was a
lot we were talking about this in the
green room beforehand there's a lot of
sort of Ang's sometimes about brexit
which is meaningless because people are
not thinking things through and a ton of
the great idea is effectively to have an
EV the system it does work it works in
the status works elsewhere it does have
to downsize that might not please people
one is the government still has to trace
people who came here but you know what's
meant by an EV the system it's like when
you go to the state's you actually apply
online to go to the states or if you
want to go to Australia you apply all
night to go to Australia they check you
before had to make sure you're the right
sort of person they want you so you
think I mean what they could do this at
the Eurostar terminal in so they can
we're talking about thousands of people
say so before you come you can do it and
then your passport is automatically
checked and either says yes it says no
the problem with the EV is a system is
if you're coming to work you have to
have a different kind of visa that's
number one and number two it says in the
article that we're going to demand that
people come to live here quite rightly I
supported speak english and i look
forward to going to Spain with the half
a million or people who brits like me
who live in south of Spain speaking
Spanish because I'm fell off with them
speaking English to wait as a con quite
understandably well that's out it in
there Suzanne another story I mean this
is all all dimensions of the same issue
this scene inside the Sun and we heard
some tough talk didn't we at their
conservative party conference from amber
Rudd the Home Secretary about some
deporting foreign criminals it turns out
well up to this point it isn't happening
the Tories have been talking tough on
de14 forum Brooks for quite some time
but it's simply not working it's all
talk and no action and the story in the
Sun today says that just two out of four
hundred and fifty three foreign
criminals have been kicked out of the
united kingdom once they serve this I'm
some so they're released from jail in
there and they stay here and they stay
you know lawyers jump on the bandwagon
managed to get them staying under human
rights legislation it's interesting
there's also a piece in the expressed
today about Abu Hamza trying to get back
into the United Kingdom saying these
lawyers are saying there's a strong
humanitarian case that it would be
better for him on health grounds to be
incarcerated here oh my heart bleeds sod
off sorry
come back no there's too much going on
there were also reports earlier in the
week which horrified me that there is an
Islamic hate preacher who says gay men
should be burned and beheaded to death
or burn to death and beheaded and he's
actually teaching here in a school run
by the Iranian government what do you
think the rhetoric doesn't match up to
the action you know it's know a lot of
breaks the tears are saying Theresa
May's fantastic she's taking us out of
the EU but let's not forget you don't
see what does help okay it's not that
Jenny nervous might play into sokka's
expertise as well although plenty of
expertise there on the Border's pensions
revolution this on the front of the
Telegraph oh yeah this certainly didn't
play into any expertise I've got just
into my your interest might well we've
got the Autumn Statement coming ups well
I'm glad see that governments trying to
do something imaginative which is that
it's looking at the fact that pension
funds can only get very low returns now
because there's such low interest rates
and so they're coming up with the idea
that instead of just getting pensions to
put their money out in the stock market
they can actually invest them in
government infrastructure projects like
hs2 like nuclear power stations like
railways games the scandalous
underpinning of this is that the reason
that ministers are suggesting it is
because we pay as taxpayers such big
profits to the companies who come in and
do this it says here that yearly returns
of ten percent and what uncommon so in
other words we as taxpayers are being
allowing exactly we've been allowing
private companies to get away with ten
percent profits well and at least
abilities now saying that's what ten
percent I mean yes you also wondered
invest in this then for that kind of
return where do things to say about the
story the first one is by the way of
course pension schemes have been
investing in infrastructure for a long
time and in development I mean look at
what Hermes we've done we were the one
who developed on the bare pensioners
this is a sketch now they saw the whole
of Kings Cross it's not but it's
important actually because we should use
but look this forgive me we should use
the capital of this country the savings
of this pool are the capital of working
men and women ordinary people like you
me this is the money that finances this
country the issue that this highlights
is that because of low interest rates
the returns are very low that means that
ordinary working men and women will not
have enough to retire on and that's the
case story and of course it should be
invested in infrastructure for this
country
yes i will make itself which we invest
okay invested but just was very briefly
i mean how does it how does it give them
then a nation then it has it's over a
trillion pounds worth of debt growing
deficit obviously afford a ten percent
return so so the that is also a question
that the investments us have to be done
have to be done in a way that actually
are holistic in their returns and
forgive me I'll go back to King's Cross
Kings Cross is a place where we
redevelop 60 acres not as expansionist
60 acres of of inner-city but what we
did was we are creating a holistic
society the returns are too ordinary
working men and women affordable housing
right inventing that free school so
there is a partnership to be done
between the owners of capital for all of
us they will see what sir see where
Chancellor and they already already
wealthy isn't it you know taxpayers are
where you paying too much for these
infrastructure projects the ones you can
afford to invest in it are the ones that
are going to be able to afford an
investor the rest of us struggle okay
listen we're nearly out of time so I
want to get all your views on the Donald
Trump farrago facing a backlash you've
got this story minutes in somebody baby
Suzanne you've got it facing a backlash
over these college yeah i mean like
number one question is why is anyone
surprised about thing this man has
demonstrated time and time again that
he's sexist misogynist all the rest of
it why is anyone surprised i have to
have to laugh actually his wife's
statement if a statement was never
written by the person that's alleged to
have said it but by a spin doctor this
is it he has experiences oh well you
know but this is certainly that he has
the heart and mind of a leader you know
yeah but his brains in his pants yeah
well Nigel well Nigel Farage is out
there for the debate and he seems to
think I us bit of banter I there's no
excuses for this you know but but I am
doing what Nigel son i do cuz you said
this is just alpha male boasting I wrote
I don't think well as your men do I
should also add yeah and I'm sorry how
am I missing some men in power so no
measles wrong not just wrong on this I
don't think there's any excuses Petrovic
nitrogen or they tie up to support
trumpet tonight's rally I I wouldn't be
there supporting Trump personally but
can I be okay today ideal for doing
pushing me as I am can I say because
there's only one could why not to
condemn him as rise tread I don't think
there's any excuses for what Trump has
said but I also must highlight
Hillary Clinton's hypocracy here you
know if Trump's had any fantasies about
cigars and the Oval Office and young
interns in a navy blue dress whose fault
is that rageous to blame there's nothing
for husband Vinny baby she has eyes for
champ she covered up for they respond
just in a sense like his size ring to
create these two things you can't equate
yeah you can't equate Trump's verbal
attacks on women and his armors your
sexual I think I found these hands that
this is jay from sandwich with something
you can I think what do you think this
is the end of this calendar to see you
should stand out I think any more
organized should stand down I'm
completely with you you you cannot blame
a woman because I but you don't know I'm
not Annie but Vittorio's what scares
mock rathi and the what I'm scared is
actually it might not derail him I mean
the United States is very different and
he has a lot of support in parts of the
states which are very different in the
way there'll be my timeline overnight my
twitter timeline and I started
criticizing Trump the number of men who
came back saying absolutely obscene
things to me all right oh it's appalling
defending him ism this is what men do
you know these do it sorry men do not do
this this is not I saw saying thats okay
listen thank you all very much deeper
taking us through some very important
stories in the papers day very good to
see you all